This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The year was 1982, and on the eastern edge of Pennsylvania, in the small city of Allentown, sat an AM radio station called WSAN. For years it had broadcast country music to the surrounding Lehigh Valley, an area known for malls, manufacturing, and Mac trucks, but the station was about to undergo a complete identity change. Well WSAN was coming off being a country station and becoming an nostalgia station. This is Ned Teeter. He was a DJ at WSAN at the time. And he says that as the station transitioned to nostalgia, meaning big band and soft hits from the 50s,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。那是 1982 年，在宾夕法尼亚州东部一个叫阿伦敦的小城市里，有一家名为 WSAN 的 AM 广播电台。多年来，它一直向周边的利哈伊山谷播放乡村音乐，这个地区以购物中心、制造业和马克卡车而闻名，但这家电台即将经历一次彻底的身份转变。当时 WSAN 正从一家乡村音乐电台转型为一家怀旧音乐电台。这是内德·蒂特尔。他当时是 WSAN 的一名 DJ。他说，随着电台转型为怀旧音乐——也就是 50 年代的交响乐流行曲和轻柔金曲，
they wanted a gimmick to hook new listeners, something to lure people to the sweet sounds of the Andrew Sisters and Perry Como. So you had FM radio stations playing music with really nice fidelity. And then you had us playing music. So you had to be a little bit different. So, you know, they're shutting up and playing the hits. We're injecting something different into our air sound in this contest. Well, that was a little different.
他们想要一个噱头来吸引新听众，用安德鲁斯姐妹和佩里·科莫的甜美歌声把人们诱惑过来。当时有些 FM 广播电台播放的音乐音质非常好。然后是我们播出的音乐。所以你必须有点与众不同。所以，你知道的，他们是不废话直接播金曲。我们在这次比赛中为我们的空中之声注入了不同的元素。嗯，这确实有点不同。
A contest. WSAN decided it would launch a good old fashioned endurance contest, reminiscent of the pole-sitting stunts and dance marathons popular in the 1920s. The station secured a local sponsor called Love Homes to donate a prize, a single-wide modular home worth $18,000. And then they devised the scheme. WSAN had a billboard in Lehigh Valley advertising
一场比赛。WSAN 决定举办一场老式的耐力比赛，让人想起 20 世纪 20 年代流行的爬竿特技和舞蹈马拉松。电台找了一家名为 Love Homes 的当地赞助商来捐赠奖品：一栋价值 18,000 美元的单宽组合屋。接着他们策划了这个方案。WSAN 在利哈伊山谷竖起了一块广告牌，宣传
the new Nistalgia Music format. They would get three contestants to ascend a 30-foot ladder to the billboard platform. And whoever stayed on that platform the longest would walk away with the new home. WSAN called it, that you'll love to live with us contest. It began in September of last year when radio station WSAN challenged their Lehigh Valley listeners to see who could stay the longest on a tiny shelf 30 feet above a highway intersection.
他们全新的怀旧音乐频道。他们会让三名参赛者爬上一根 30 英尺高的梯子，登上广告牌平台。谁能在那个平台上坚持到最后，就能把这栋新房子带回家。WSAN 将其命名为“你一定会爱上和我们一起生活”比赛。比赛始于去年 9 月，当时 WSAN 电台向利哈伊山谷的听众发起挑战，看谁能在高速公路交叉口上方 30 英尺高的小平台上坚持最长时间。
It was supposed to be a way to get people to know we had changed our format, look at our billboard, and give away a modular home for a sponsor. That's what this was supposed to be. It's not what it was. WSAN had grossly underestimated just how much people would endure for a little economic security. I don't know if this law of attraction or what, but I mean, in the weeks leading up to the contest, people were asking me, oh, you're out of the army.
这本该是一种让人们知道我们改变了节目形式、关注我们的广告牌、并为赞助商送出一栋组合屋的方式。这本该是它的意义所在。但实际情况并非如此。WSAN 严重低估了人们为了获得一点经济安全感而能够忍受的程度。我不知道这是吸引力法则还是什么，但我的意思是，在比赛开始前的几周里，人们一直在问我：“哦，你退伍了。”
You've been away. What are you going to do? I said, I'm going to be in this contest. This was before they even drew my name. This is Dalton Young, one of the three contestants that would eventually be chosen by WSAN. He was 22 years old at the time. He just been discharged from the army the month before. And he thought that sitting on a billboard above a highway sounded like as good an option
你离开好久了。你打算做什么？”我说：“我要去参加这个比赛。”这甚至还在他们抽中我的名字之前。这是道尔顿·扬，最终被 WSAN 选中的三名参赛者之一。他当时 22 岁。就在前一个月，他刚刚从军队退伍。他觉得坐在高速公路上方的广告牌上听起来是一个不错的选择，
as any. Yeah, I mean, the economy was really not good at that time. Unemployment was outrageous. Dalton was so dead set on competing that he turned in a thousand entries. He'd carefully read the submission rules and realized that there was no specified limit to the number of times a person could submit. And it turned out he wasn't the only one who'd read the fine print and had a lot of time on their hands. Here's Ron Kisler with his wife Sue.
不比别的差。是的，我的意思是，当时的经济状况确实很糟糕。失业率简直离谱。道尔顿铁了心要参赛，于是他交了一千份报名表。他仔细阅读了提交规则，发现并没有规定个人可以提交的次数上限。事实证明，他并不是唯一一个读过细则且空闲时间很多的人。这位是罗恩·基斯勒和他的妻子苏。
Something to do. Ron's not the chattyest person in the world, but what he lacked in conversation he made up for with determination. When he heard about the contest, he and Sue hand delivered over 4,000 entries directly to the WSAN station. I think we were trying for 4,000 when we added up and came up to 4,000 and 4, so that's what we send in. Ron and Sue had been dating for a year before the contest, and they were looking to move in together. This seemed like the perfect opportunity to get a place of their own.
找点事做。罗恩并不是世界上最健谈的人，但他缺乏交谈的能耐，却用坚定的意志弥补了回来。当他听到这个比赛的消息时，他和苏亲手将 4,000 多份报名表直接送到了 WSAN 电台。我想我们当时是奔着 4,000 份去的，当我们加起来发现刚好是 4,004 份时，我们就把这些都交上去了。罗恩和苏在比赛前已经交往了一年，他们正准备搬到一起住。这似乎是获得属于他们自己的房子的绝佳机会。
I thought it was a quick and easy way to get a house. The last of the contestants was Mike McKay. He died in 2006. Back in the early 1980s, he was the only one of the three contestants who was married, and he was the only one who had a job. But even still, he couldn't afford to buy a home. McKay sent in an astronomical 47,000 entries to WSAN. He used a rubber stamp with the phrase, I need a home, and then cut out and signed every piece of paper. He submitted so many times the first 10 entries pulled by the selection team were his.
我以为这是一个快速且轻松获得房子方法。最后一位参赛者是迈克·麦凯。他在 2006 年去世了。早在 20 世纪 80 年代初，他是三名参赛者中唯一结了婚的，也是唯一一个有工作的人。但即便如此，他仍然买不起房。麦凯向 WSAN 提交了惊人的 47,000 份报名表。他用了一枚刻有“我需要一个家”字样的橡皮图章，然后剪下并签署了每一张纸。他交的次数太多了，以至于选拔团队抽出的前 10 张报名表全都是他的。
Yeah, my first impression of Mike was that he was kind of a winback, you know, kind of a full of bluster. Again, Dalton Young. But, you know, if you could get past all the bluster, you know, just had a big heart, you know, it's just a really nice guy, I think. Between the three of them, Dalton, Ron, and Mike submitted 52,000 four entries, and this sounds like a lot until you consider just how many total entries there were. The station received over half a million submissions. We had like Miracle on 34th Street, right? These bags of postcards on the conference table just piled up high.
对，我对迈克的第一印象是他有点像个大话精，你知道的，就是那种满嘴大话的人。再次由道尔顿·扬讲述。但是，你知道的，如果你能抛开那些大话，你会发现他其实有一颗善良的心，你知道的，他真的是个很好的人。他们三个人——道尔顿、罗恩和迈克总共提交了 52,004 份报名表，听起来很多，但如果你考虑到总共有多少份报名表，就会觉得这不算什么了。电台收到了超过五十万份投稿。就像《34街的奇迹》那样，对吧？会议桌上堆满了装有明信片的袋子。
There was a reason they were getting so many entries. Around the time the competition launched, the country was slogging through the worst recession it had seen in over 40 years. The recession began in 1981 when the Fed raised interest rates to try to fight rising inflation. It then dragged on all the way through 1982. Companies cut their spending to try to cope, and hundreds of steel facilities and manufacturing plants closed, including some in the Lehigh Valley. Places like Allentown, where WSAM was located, were hit particularly hard.
他们收到这么多报名表是有原因的。正值比赛开幕前后，国家正在经历 40 多年来最严重的经济衰退。经济衰退始于 1981 年，当时美联储为了对抗不断上升的通货膨胀而提高了利率。随后，这种状况一直持续到了 1982 年整整一年。为了应对危机，各大公司纷纷削减开支，数百家钢铁厂和制造厂倒闭，其中包括利哈伊山谷的一些工厂。像 WSAM 所在的阿伦敦这样的小镇受到的冲击尤其严重。
You gotta remember that this is ground- the rust belt, blue collar town. Steel's gone, Mac Trucks is threatened to leave, Champion Spark plugs is closed. The National Unemployment Rate was the highest since the Great Depression. An interest rate skyrocketed to 20% in 1982. If you were a blue collar worker and didn't already own a house at this time, it would be incredibly tough to get one. To many people, the idea of spending a little time on a billboard for a chance to win a home must have seemed like a pretty good deal.
你得记住，这是——铁锈带的蓝领小镇。钢铁厂没了，马克卡车威胁要搬走，冠军火花塞厂也关门了。全国失业率达到了大萧条以来的最高点。1982 年，利率飙升至 20%。如果你是一名蓝领工人，而且当时还没有自己的房子，想要买一套简直难如登天。对许多人来说，在广告牌上待上一段时间就有机会赢得一套房子，这听起来绝对是一笔非常划算的买卖。
People were looking for better times, better days. And that was a big part of this. This is kind of like a rust belt fairy tale. The contest officially started on September 20th, 1982. Dalton Young, Ron Kisler, and Mike McKay ascended the billboard to begin their stay. Towering behind them was an advertisement for the station, reading unforgettable 1470 WSAN. Here's Dalton again. Yeah, it was raining that day.
人们都在寻找更好的时代、更好的日子。这是其中很大一部分原因。这有点像一部铁锈带的童话故事。比赛于 1982 年 9 月 20 日正式开始。道尔顿·扬、罗恩·基斯勒和迈克·麦凯登上广告牌，开始了他们的滞留生活。在他们身后高高耸立的是电台的广告牌，上面写着“难忘的 1470 WSAN”。这里又是道尔顿。对，那天在下雨。
I remember it was kind of drizzly and crappy, a little bit damp and cold. And, you know, there was traffic blown by raining that day. I remember it was kind of drizzly and crappy, a little bit damp and cold. And, you know, it was traffic blown by throughout the day. Plains flying right overhead because it was right near the Lehigh Valley Airport. This was supposed to be a VELA 30 day event. This is Gene Wurley, another DJ at WSAN, and one of the contest organizers. Well, the name officially is Gene Wurley,
我记得当时有点毛毛雨，天气很糟，又潮湿又冷。而且，你知道的，那天雨中车流滚滚。飞机就在头顶上飞过，因为这里离利哈伊山谷机场很近。这本该是一个持续 30 天的活动。这是吉恩·沃利，WSAN 的另一位 DJ，也是比赛组织者之一。嗯，我的官方名字叫吉恩·沃利，
but almost everybody around here would call me early Whirly, and came from doing the morning shows. Whirly said that besides some local coverage when the guys went up, there wasn't that much fanfare around the contest in the beginning. Even though WSAN had launched the contest as a kind of promotion, they didn't do the best job of promoting it
但这里的几乎每个人都叫我“呼呼沃利”（Whirly），这个绰号是因为我以前主持早间节目。沃利说，除了这几位小伙子上去时的一些当地报道之外，比赛一开始并没有引起多大轰动。尽管 WSAN 发起这场比赛是为了某种宣传，但他们并没有在与其他媒体的合作推广上做好充分的工作
with other media outlets. It was going on, people just weren't made aware of it. There wasn't mention on the other radio stations that they might have listened to. There weren't articles in the newspaper. There wasn't anything on the TV news that they watched. The accommodations on the Billboard were pretty bare bones. Each guy had a small tent, a radio, a landline telephone, and a chemical toilet, which is kind of like a tiny portapoddy.
宣传。比赛正在进行，人们只是没有意识到这一点。他们平时听的其他广播电台里没有提及此事。报纸上也没有相关文章。他们看的电视新闻里也没有任何报道。广告牌上的住宿条件非常简陋。每个人只有一个小帐篷、一台收音机、一部固定电话和一个化学厕所，这有点像一个微型便携式马桶。
It was almost like camping, only you were 30 feet in the air, surrounded by freeway traffic, and trapped on a billboard. We made the guys comfortable, we didn't torture them, we had your tents, you had everything going on in there. The billboard platform itself was about eight feet by 48 feet, and it had been divided into three equal sections by waist-high partitions. The organizers at WSAN wanted the contest to last long enough to draw some attention, but not forever.
这几乎就像是在露营，只不过你身处 30 英尺的高空，周围环绕着高速公路的车流，并且被困在广告牌上。我们让小伙子们过得舒服点，没有折磨他们，我们有帐篷，里面应有尽有。广告牌平台本身大约是 8 英尺乘 48 英尺，并被腰高的隔板分成了三个相等的区域。WSAN 的组织者希望比赛持续足够长的时间以吸引一些眼球，但又不能没完没了。
They figured that by discouraging interaction between the contestants, they might keep the whole thing to a reasonable length. Yeah, we didn't talk at all for, you know, I don't even know we said hi to each other. But even if the guys weren't encouraged to interact with each other, they still had plenty of people to keep them company, from a distance. The contest required that the guys have their own support team to deliver food and to handle cleanup. Each contestant had a pulley system so they could raise or lower supplies in buckets or
他们认为，通过阻止参赛者之间的互动，他们可能会把整场活动控制在合理的长度内。是的，我们根本不说话，甚至——我甚至不知道我们有没有互相打过招呼。但即便这些小伙子们不被鼓励互相交流，他们身边仍然有很多人陪伴，当然是保持着一定距离。比赛要求这些小伙子们有自己的后勤团队来运送食物和处理垃圾。每个参赛者都有一个滑轮系统，这样他们就可以用桶或
on trays. Dalton's friends and families stopped by all the time to chat from below, Mike had his wife, and Ron's parents made sure he got everything he needed, and got rid of the things he didn't. Here's Sue Kisler. Well, his parents did a lot too, as far as bringing food. His dad was in charge of emptying the port of John. That was his job.
托盘上下运送物资。道尔顿的朋友和家人经常顺道过来，在下面跟他说说话；迈克有他的妻子；罗恩的父母则确保他得到所需的一切，并把不需要的东西拿走。这是苏·基斯勒。嗯，他的父母也付出了很多，比如送食物。他父亲负责清理流动厕所。那是他的工作。
Sue and Ron were dating at the time, and Sue visited Ron every day except one when he was up on the billboard. Strangely enough, the contest might have even made their relationship stronger. Well, that's all we could do was talk, so we got to know each other a lot better in that time, because we talked every day and on the phone or with me at the bottom of the billboard. Aside from the essentials, each contestant was allowed to bring a non-essential item with them.
苏和罗恩当时正在交往，除了罗恩在广告牌上的那一天外，苏每天都来看望他。说来也怪，这场比赛甚至可能让他们的感情变得更加深厚。嗯，我们能做的只有聊天，所以在那段时间里我们对彼此有了更深的了解，因为我们每天都在聊天，要么在电话里，要么我在广告牌下面。除了必需品外，每个参赛者还可以带一件非必需品。
Mike McKay brought a guitar which he learned to play up there. Ron Kisler brought a copy of American Rifleman magazine. And Dalton. Yeah, I had some numb jokes up there. In fact, I think I got them as a gift for my birthday, maybe it was. As you can imagine, there was little room to do anything, and even less when Dalton had his numb jucks out. But there wasn't much to do, period.
迈克·麦凯带了一把吉他，他在上面学会了弹吉他。罗恩·基斯勒带了一本《美国步枪手》杂志。还有道尔顿。对，我在上面带了一些双节棍。事实上，我想它们是我生日时收到的礼物，也许吧。正如你所想象的那样，上面几乎没有活动空间，当道尔顿拿出他的双节棍时，空间就更小了。不过说实话，上面本来也没什么事可做。
Here's Ron Kisler on his daily schedule. Um, you know, wake up, have something for breakfast. This is the radio, hang out, have have something for supper and what's traffic? The routine was mind-numbing. Days quietly crept by, then months, September. Oh, wake up, I have something for breakfast. October. What's traffic?
这里是罗恩·基斯勒讲述他的日常生活。嗯，你知道的，醒来，吃点早餐。听听收音机，闲逛，吃点晚餐，看看车流情况？这种日复一日的生活极其枯燥。日子静静地流逝，接着是几个月，9 月。哦，醒来，吃点早餐。10 月。看看车流情况？
November. This is the radio. But if they were listening to the radio in November, they might have heard a new song. One that would help transform their sleepy lives up on the billboard into something much bigger But if they were listening to the radio in November, they might have heard a new song, one that would help transform their sleepy lives up on the Billboard into something much bigger and stranger. The song was by Billy Joel.
11 月。听听收音机。但如果他们在 11 月收听广播，他们可能会听到一首新歌。一首能将他们在广告牌上乏味的生活转变为更大事情的歌曲……但如果他们在 11 月收听广播，他们可能会听到一首新歌，一首能将他们在广告牌上乏味的生活转变为更大、更奇特的经历的歌曲。这首歌是比利·乔尔唱的。
And November of 1982, the song Allentown started climbing the Billboard charts, and it happened to be about the very town where WSAN was located. The song painted a vivid portrait of the economic hardship working class families were going through at the time. He was talking about companies like Bethlehem Steel and the Lehigh Valley, shutting its doors and eliminating nearly 10,000 jobs. Because of the song, the city of Allentown became a kind of stand-in for all the suffering rust belt towns in the Northeast and Midwest. Here's Dalton Young again.
在 1982 年 11 月，歌曲《阿伦敦》开始在公告牌排行榜上攀升，而这首歌恰好唱的就是 WSAN 所在地的那座小镇。这首歌生动地描绘了当时工人阶级家庭所经历的经济困境。他谈到了像伯利恒钢铁公司和利哈伊山谷这样的公司，它们纷纷关门大吉，裁掉了近 1 万个工作岗位。因为这首歌，阿伦敦市成为了东北部和中西部所有遭受苦难的铁锈带城镇的某种代名词。再次由道尔顿·扬讲述。
I think he was talking about the economy, and it just happened that this contest was going on, and it wasn't stated that this contest is because the economy is so bad and we're going to try to give somebody a home that might not otherwise have one. But yeah, they both seem to work together really well. People started paying attention to Allentown and the contest. 81 days on the billboard from Mike McCay, Daphan Young and Ron Pistley in our WSAN, the 11 times you're left to live with this contest and so on. They're hanging in there. Pretty good.
我想他当时是在谈论经济问题，而这场比赛恰好正在进行，虽然官方并没有明说这场比赛是因为经济太糟糕，我们要试着给一个原本可能买不起房的人一套房子。但是，是的，这两件事似乎配合得非常好。人们开始关注阿伦敦和这场比赛。迈克·麦凯、道尔顿·扬和罗恩·基斯勒在 WSAN 的广告牌上坚持了 81 天，参加“你一定会爱上和我们一起生活”比赛等等。他们正在坚持。相当不错。
And as this media coverage expanded, stories about the contest started to hit national newspapers. On December 9, 1982, an article appeared in the Wall Street Journal and the response was immediate. The phones were ringing constantly all the lines. Here's Gene Early-Wirly, the WSA in DJ. And I have no idea what they're saying, except they're talking about people on a billboard. So by the time we got off the air, some information was gathered that said the Wall Street Journal
随着媒体报道的扩大，关于这场比赛的故事开始登上全国各大报纸。1982 年 12 月 9 日，《华尔街日报》上发表了一篇文章，反响非常热烈。所有的电话都在响，所有的线路都被打爆了。这是吉恩·厄利-惠利（Gene Early-Wirly），WSAN 的 DJ。我根本不知道他们在说什么，只知道他们在谈论广告牌上的人。所以等我们下节目的时候，收集到了一些信息，说《华尔街日报》
did a front page article on the billboard. Suddenly this little AM radio station which only had about a 50 mile range was peaking a lot of interest. Allentown, Pennsylvania has been receiving international publicity, no kidding from all over the world. You know, before social media and really even before the internet, some stories just did that and you didn't even really know how. This is Betsy Morris, the staff reporter at the Wall Street Journal who wrote that article.
在头版刊登了一篇关于广告牌的文章。突然之间，这家信号覆盖范围只有大约 50 英里的微型 AM 广播电台引起了巨大的关注。宾夕法尼亚州的阿伦敦正在接受国际媒体的采访，来自世界各地的报道，真的不是开玩笑。你知道的，在社交媒体出现之前，甚至在互联网出现之前，有些故事就是能产生这种效果，你甚至不知道它是怎么做到的。这是贝茨·莫里斯，《华尔街日报》负责撰写那篇文章的专职记者。
Morris didn't expect the story to catch on like it did. Because of her story, Dalton, Ron, and Mike were fielding questions from people magazine, Rolling Stone, and Phil Donhue about their extended stay on the billboard. Dalton even remembers getting calls from Japan, New Zealand, and, on the landlines that they had up on the board. A French magazine ran a story in France about the contest, and for whatever reason, they put each of our phone numbers in the article. So all of a sudden, we're getting 150 calls a day from French people. You have no idea when you're writing stories stories which ones are going to hit a nerve.
莫里斯没有想到这个故事会像后来那样广受欢迎。多亏了她的报道，道尔顿、罗恩和迈克开始应付来自《人物》杂志、《滚石》杂志和菲尔·多纳休的提问，讲述他们在广告牌上长期滞留的经历。道尔顿甚至记得接到了来自日本、新西兰的电话，就打在他们挂在广告牌上的固定电话上。法国的一本杂志在法国发表了一篇关于这场比赛的报道，不知出于什么原因，他们在文章中登出了我们每个人的电话号码。所以突然之间，我们每天都会接到 150 个来自法国人的电话。当你写故事时，你根本不知道哪个故事会触动人们的神经。
I mean, it was interesting to look back and see all those, all that paparazzi outside the billboard later. But looking back, Betsy Morris understood why this particular story resonated. Then President Ronald Reagan had referred to America as the shining city upon a hill. But life was so hard in that shining city that three men had confined themselves to a billboard for months, all for a chance to win a home. There was something dystopian about it. I mean, the American dream was really shaky at that point. And while the guys in the billboard never said they felt exploited by the radio station, an air of desperation
我的意思是，回过头来看看到后来广告牌外面那些长枪短炮的狗仔队，真的很有趣。但回过头来看，贝茨·莫里斯理解为什么这个特定的故事能引起共鸣。当时的总统罗纳德·里根曾将美国称为“山巅之城”。但那座闪耀之城的生活是如此艰难，以至于三名男子为了赢得一套房子的机会，竟然在广告牌上把自己关了几个月。这其中带有一种反乌托邦的色彩。我的意思是，当时的美国梦已经变得摇摇欲坠。虽然广告牌上的小伙子们从未表示过他们觉得自己受到了电台的剥削，但随着时间的推移，一种绝望的气氛
did begin to seep into the contest as the months went by. How long do you think you'll be here? Well, maybe two years. I don't know. Depending on that, mostly. Sorry, I run that by again. I'd say probably two years. Maybe a year and nine months, a year and eight months,
确实开始在比赛中弥漫开来。你觉得你会在上面待多久？嗯，也许两年吧。我不知道。主要取决于那个。抱歉，能再说一遍吗？我想大概两年吧。也许一年九个月，一年八个月，
come down for summer of 84, some of the summer person. They asked us how long we would stay up there, and I said, I don't know, two or three years, then I really meant it. I wasn't just provato, but I figured, okay, in order to save enough to get an $18,000 home, what would I be willing to invest in time, and I fought two to three years?
下来的时候已经是 84 年的夏天了，成了夏天的人。他们问我们会在上面待多久，我说，我不知道，两三年吧，我当时真的是这么想的。我可不是在虚张声势，我当时想，好吧，为了省下买一栋 18,000 美元房子的钱，我愿意付出多少时间投资，而我估计的是两到三年？
When December and January arrived, it started getting colder. The lowest recorded temperature was zero degrees Fahrenheit, so the guys were giving portable heaters to keep them from dying. A huge no-storm shut down the entire city, but it didn't stop the contest. According to Dalton, it was a welcome change of pace.
当 12 月和 1 月来临时，天气开始变冷了。记录到的最低温度是华氏零度，因此电台给小伙子们发了便携式取暖器，以免他们冻死。一场巨大的暴风雪瘫痪了整个城市，但并没有叫停比赛。据道尔顿说，这反而是个受欢迎的生活调剂。
For me, it was a piece of cake. For know, for that, whatever, 24 hours or however long, 48 hours, the late Doug, everything out, it was, it was peaceful. You know, it was just so quiet and so peaceful. It was great. Actually, given everything the guys were going through, the isolation, the weather, the boredom, they were holding up surprisingly well. Here's an interview with Ron around the same time. The temperature has dropped to zero, most snow 24 inches. You must be talking to yourselves,
对我来说，这简直是小菜一碟。你知道的，在那，不管多久，24小时或者48小时里，一切都慢了下来，这很平静。你知道，它是如此安静，如此平静。这感觉太棒了。事实上，考虑到这些小伙子们所经历的一切——孤立、恶劣的天气、无聊，他们的心理状态好得惊人。这是大约在同一时期对罗恩的采访。气温已经降到了零度，降雪量达 24 英寸。你们一定是在自言自语，
but how are you doing psychologically? Oh, I'm fine. You know. Okay. Don't Ron and Mike all made it through the winter and lasted into the spring. At this point, they'd spent Thanksgiving, Christmas,
但你们的心理状态怎么样？哦，我挺好的。你知道的。好吧。罗恩和迈克都熬过了冬天，并一直坚持到了春天。此时，他们已经度过了感恩节、圣诞节、
New Years, and Valentine's Day away from their families, and still nobody intended to come down. And then finally, in March of 1983, after six months of basically nothing happening, something happened. It was one morning there was a guy out talking to Ron and Mike. A stranger that Dalton hadn't seen before was down below the billboard chatting with the guys.
新年和情人节，全都是远离家人的状态，然而仍然没有人打算下来。直到最后，在 1983 年 3 月，经历了整整六个月几乎什么都没发生的日子之后，终于出事了。那天早上，有个陌生人在下面跟罗恩和迈克说话。一个道尔顿以前没见过的陌生人在广告牌下方跟小伙子们聊天。
He casually struck up a conversation with Dalton telling him that he was also a veteran. And we were talking about our experiences in the military and some of the partying we had done. At some point, I asked me if I got high and I thought at that point, we had some sort of a bond, yeah sure, I get high. I mean, he was on a billboard for six months. He asked me if I could get him some and I said, well, I gotta have a little like it part with.
他漫不经心地跟道尔顿搭话，告诉他自己也是一名退伍军人。我们当时在谈论我们在军队里的经历以及我们曾经参加过的一些派对。在某个时候，他问我有没有吸过大麻，我觉得在那一刻，我们之间似乎建立某种纽带，于是我说，当然啦，我吸过。我的意思是，他在广告牌上待了六个月呢。他问我能不能给他弄点，我说，好吧，我身上确实带了一点。
So he stuck it in a cigarette pack and dropped it down to him. Dalton lowered down two joints and the stranger thanked him with a $20 bill. But I said, look man, really, just take it. He's an annoyanceist, I'm a cyst. And I thought, well, I don't, you know, 20 bucks, 20 bucks, I'm not gonna turn it down, you know? him with a $20 bill. I get a phone call early in the morning probably before 5 o'clock. This is Mike Chrysah, executive director of the HGF group, the company that was funding
于是他把大麻塞进烟盒里扔了下去。道尔顿往下扔了两个大麻烟卷，陌生人拿出一张 20 美元的钞票向他表示感谢。但我说：“听着，伙计，真的，你拿去吧。他是助长者，我是顺从者。”我当时想，好吧，你知道的，20 块钱嘛，20 块钱，我总不能不要吧，你知道吗？他用一张 20 美元的钞票报答了他。一大清早我就接到了电话，大概不到五点钟。这是迈克·克里萨（Mike Chrysah），HGF 集团的执行董事，该公司是资助
the contest. He remembers getting a call from a contest organizer saying, you're going to have a good time telling the boss this one. Dalton got busted for drugs. I says, what? I says, how can it be selling drugs from, you know, 2030 feet up on a billboard? Apparently the stranger who'd solicited the pot from Dalton had been an undercover police officer because Dalton accepted that $20.
这场比赛的公司。他记得接到了一位比赛组织者的电话，对方说：“你跟老板说这个消息的时候可有得乐了。道尔顿因为毒品被抓了。”我说：“什么？怎么可能有人在广告牌上——距地面 20、30 英尺高的地方贩毒呢？”显然，那个向道尔顿索要大麻的陌生人是一名便衣警察，因为道尔顿收下了那 20 美元。
He was arrested on drug charges. It made the front page of the, uh, the Philadelphia inquire and I think the same day that the Reagan announced his missile defense system. So there's Reagan's missile defense system, and there's a Dalton being busted on the front page. Dalton was knocked out of the competition on day 184. I'm probably the only person in history to be arrested, so I'm part from a billboard.
他因涉嫌毒品指控被捕。这登上了《费城问询报》的头版，我想就在里根宣布他的导弹防御系统的那天。所以一边是里根的导弹防御系统，另一边是道尔顿因吸毒被捕上了头版。道尔顿在第 184 天被淘汰出局。我可能是历史上第一个因为在广告牌上吸毒而被捕的人。
And yes, there were plenty of rumors that Dalton had been set up. Maybe one of the other guys reported him to the police, or maybe one of the contest sponsors wanted to speed along the end of the contest. None of this was actually proven, but you gotta admit, it's really, really fishy. Ron and Mike both descended from the billboard to testify in court. They had breakfast, a quick shower, and then went right back up on the billboard to finish out the contest. But after Dalton's arrest, the competition felt different. Here's Ned Teter again, one of the WSAM DJs.
当然，有很多传言称道尔顿是被陷害的。也许是其他某个小伙子向警方举报了他，或者也许是某个比赛赞助商想加快比赛的结束。这些都没有得到实际证实，但你不得不承认，这真的非常非常可疑。罗恩和迈克都从广告牌上下来出庭作证。他们吃了早餐，冲了个快澡，然后又立刻回到广告牌上继续完成比赛。但在道尔顿被捕后，比赛的气氛变了。再次由 WSAN 的 DJ 内德·蒂特尔讲述。
We have this contest and these people are becoming every man here. And it's a great story. It's heartwarming. And then over two joints of marijuana, Dalton gets pulled off the boat. And I think that's when things changed. I think that's when things went from how is this thing going to end to... how are we going to end this thing?
我们举办了这个比赛，这些人变成了我们身边的普通人。这是一个很棒的故事。它很暖心。然后因为两支大麻烟，道尔顿被弄下了广告牌。我想这就是事情改变的时候。我想这就是事情从“这场比赛该怎么收场”转变为“我们该怎么结束这场比赛”的时候。
By this point, the competition had become a huge annoyance for town officials. The town commissioner even described the contest as a hymnoid and wanted it stopped. Officials here at Town Hall, equally disillusioned with the contest, have contemplated sending the housing inspector to evict the contestants. The billboard has no plumbing or smoke alarms, and the town's already sent them bills for residency tax, listing the billboard address. But Ron Kisler and Mike McKay had dug their heels in deep. Neither would come down unless they were coming down to a new home.
到了这个时候，这场比赛已经成了镇上官员的一个巨大麻烦。镇长甚至将这场比赛形容为一个毒瘤，并希望将其叫停。市政厅的官员们同样对这场比赛感到幻灭，他们甚至考虑派遣房屋检查员来驱逐参赛者。广告牌没有管道设施或烟雾报警器，而且该镇已经给他们寄去了居住税账单，上面写着的地址就是广告牌。但罗恩·基斯勒和迈克·麦凯态度极其强硬。除非是下来住进新房子，否则他们绝不下来。
The station had received more publicity than it ever needed, and at this point it had become a burden. WSAN had the attention of the world, but nothing to say. We were radio guys, not PR guys, not marketing mavens, not really not on an international or national level. Ron and Mike lasted two months beyond Dalton's drug bust before WSAN caved and realized that enough was enough. When it became obvious neither man would quit and both threatened to stay forever if necessary,
这家电台受到的关注已经超过了它的需求，到了这个时候，它已经成了一种负担。WSAN 赢得了世界的瞩目，却无话可说。我们是广播人，而不是公关人员，不是营销达人，至少在国际或国家层面上不是。在道尔顿因涉嫌吸毒被捕两个月后，罗恩和迈克终于坚持到了 WSAN 崩溃并意识到适可而止的时候。当很明显这两个人都不会放弃，并且两人都威胁说如有必要将永远待在上面时，
the station declared the contest a draw and lured the men down by offering duplicate prizes for each. They had captured the attention of the region when they came down today. On June 7, 1983, Ron and Mike both stepped down off their respective ladders at the same time. They'd been up on the billboard for 261 days, nearly 9 months. And in that entire time, they had taken only one shower. The station had received some criticism around the contest. People had accused them of exploiting the guys. So WSAN actually upped the prizes to try to repair some of the damage done to their reputation.
电台宣布比赛为平局，并为每个人提供双倍的奖品，以此将这两人诱骗下来。当他们今天下来时，他们吸引了整个地区的目光。1983 年 6 月 7 日，罗恩和迈克同时从各自的梯子上走了下来。他们在广告牌上待了 261 天，将近 9 个月。而在那段漫长的时间里，他们只洗过一次澡。电台因这场比赛而受到了一些批评。人们指责他们剥夺和利用了这些小伙子。因此，WSAN 实际上提高了奖品规格，试图修复因声誉受损而造成的伤害。
Ron and Mike both walked away with a modular home, a Chevy Chavette, and a free vacation. This wasn't supposed to be this. It wasn't supposed to be this big international global, almost year-long thing. The men reacted very differently in their post-contest lives. Mike tried to recreate the fame he'd had when he was up on the board. That never really happened, but when he died in 2006, his obituary still referred to him by his preferred nickname, Billboard Mike. He was the guy that you would say, this was my high water mark, this defined me.
罗恩和迈克每人获得了一栋组合屋、一辆雪佛莱切威特汽车和一次免费度假。事情本不该是这样的。这本不该是一场如此宏大的国际性、全球性、持续将近一年的事件。这些小伙子们在比赛结束后的生活中反应截然不同。迈克试图重现他在广告牌上时所拥有的名气。这从未真正实现，但当他在 2006 年去世时，他的讣告中仍然使用他最喜欢的昵称“广告牌迈克”。他就是那种会说“这就是我人生的最高峰，这定义了我”的人。
I think that Mike McKay was the one that loved it the most. He loved being Billboard Mike. At least he made off better than Dalton. I got six months probation and a $100 fine. Of course I do have a felony. So. Ron Kisler's quiet determination, on the other hand, probably got him the closest to that rust belt fairy tale
我想迈克·麦凯是那个最留恋这一切的人。他很享受当“广告牌迈克”的日子。至少他的下场比道尔顿好。我被判了六个月缓刑，罚款 100 美元。当然，我确实留下了重罪案底。所以。另一方面，罗恩·基斯勒沉着坚定的毅力，可能让他最接近那个铁锈带童话般的
ending. He and Sue married shortly after the contest ended. They lived happily in their two bedroom modular home for 20 years, raised a daughter in it, and moved on with their lives. At the end of the day, you've got three guys that did something crazy to try and just get a little bit ahead of the world.
结局。他和苏在比赛结束后不久就结婚了。他们在双卧室的组合屋里幸福地生活了 20 年，并在里面抚养了一个女儿，继续着他们的生活。说到底，你看到了三个做出疯狂举动的小伙子，他们只是想在这个世界上勉强出人头地。
I mean, you remember, these guys weren't looking for a mansion or a jet plane, they're just looking for a start. ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pat Taggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pat Taggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pat Taggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special Thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's A Very Special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." ["Petka's a very special thanks to Pataggerd and Frank Petka." [" episode was adapted from their fantastic feature length documentary, Billboard Boys. It's available right now on Amazon in iTunes. What happens when you take away all the billboards? They did it in a city in Brazil. We'll talk about that after this. In Allentown, a single billboard became a much bigger sign of the times, which started as a simple radio promotion ended up shedding light on a larger economic and housing crisis. Decades later, something similar would happen in Sao Paulo, Brazil, but this time it was about the removal of billboards that revealed a bigger story, which
我的意思是，你要记住，这些小伙子们并不是在寻找豪宅或喷气式飞机，他们只是在寻找一个起步的机会。本期节目改编自他们精彩的长篇纪录片《广告牌男孩》。目前在亚马逊和 iTunes 上均可观看。当你拿掉所有的广告牌会发生什么？他们在巴西的一个城市里做了这件事。我们在接下来的节目中讨论这个。在阿伦敦，一块广告牌成为了更大的时代标志，最初作为一个简单的电台促销活动，最终揭示了更大的经济和住房危机。几十年后，类似的事情在巴西圣保罗发生，但这一次，是关于拆除广告牌却揭示了一个更大的故事，
Colestead is here to talk to us about. So in the early 2000s, São Paulo was just littered with advertisements, including around 15,000 billboards. And as this visual pollution got worse, people became increasingly frustrated, you know, at private companies being allowed to basically brand public space. So the mayor comes along and proposes a clean city law to get rid of all kinds of ads. Business signs, posters, bus ads, taxi ads, you made it, it all had to go.
柯特·科尔斯特德（Colestead）来到这里跟我们聊聊这个。因此，在 20 世纪 20 年代初，圣保罗到处都是广告，包括大约 15,000 个广告牌。随着这种视觉污染越来越严重，人们越来越感到沮丧，你知道的，私营公司竟然被允许基本上把公共空间打上自己的品牌烙印。于是市长出台了一项“清洁城市法”，旨在清除各种广告。商业招牌、海报、公交广告、出租车广告，只要你能想到的，统统都得消失。
Even handing out marketing flyers on the street would be illegal. That's so extreme. Businesses must not have been happy about that at all. Yeah, they really weren't. I mean, this was a city full of ads, and suddenly, they would be none. But this proposed law had a ton of public support, and predictably, business leaders fought back. Corporate lobbyists argued that it would be bad for the economy and would compromise real estate
甚至在街上散发传单都是非法的。这太极端了。商家们肯定对此非常不高兴。是的，他们确实很不高兴。我的意思是，这是一个充满广告的城市，突然之间，一个广告也没有了。但这项拟议中的法律得到了大量公众的支持，不出所料，商业领袖们进行了反击。企业说客认为这对经济不利，并会损害房地产
values. They also tried to scare people with the idea that public tax money would be needed to remove all the supporting infrastructure, you know, like the polls and the scaffolding around these billboards. There is even an argument that commercial graphics were useful as wayfinding devices, you know, helping people navigate the city. Plus, at night, fewer lit-up signs would make the city less safe and so on and so forth. So I guess some of those arguments make some sense, but they all seem to be rooted primarily in self-interest. Absolutely. OK.
价值。他们还试图制造恐慌，宣称需要公共税款来拆除所有的配套基础设施，你知道的，比如广告牌周围的电线杆和脚手架。甚至还有一种论点认为，商业图形可以用作寻路工具，你知道的，帮助人们在城市中导航。另外，到了晚上，发光的标志变少会让城市的安全性降低，诸如此类。所以我想其中一些论点确实有一定道理，但它们似乎主要都植根于私利。完全正确。好的。
And in the end, the business advocates lost. The law passed, and businesses were given 90 days to comply or to start paying fines. And so the ads started going down, and suddenly the city did look different. And sure, some old architecture was uncovered, which was nice, but pulling down all those ads also revealed some other hidden aspects of the city. And so what kind of things are we talking about here? So stripping away huge billboards alongside
最后，商业倡导者们失败了。该法律通过了，企业有 90 天的时间来遵守或开始支付罚款。于是广告开始撤下，突然间这座城市看起来确实不一样了。当然，一些古老的建筑重见天日，这很好，但拆除所有这些广告也暴露出这座城市一些其他隐藏的面貌。那么我们在这里谈论的是哪种事情呢？比如，剥离大型广告牌旁的
major roads, for instance, ended up exposing favelles, entire shantytown neighborhoods that had been visually fenced off by ads. And then on the sides of factories, where there were these billboards covering up windows, removing them actually revealed immigrants living where they worked. Essentially, they weren't being paid enough to afford rent. And the absence of ads in general, right, like sort of the decolorization of the city,
主干道，最终暴露出贫民窟，整个棚户区社区此前都被广告在视觉上隔绝开来。然后是在工厂的外墙上，原本有这些广告牌遮住窗户，拆除它们实际上暴露了那些住在工作场所的移民。本质上，他们没有得到足够的报酬来支付房租。而广告的整体消失，对吧，就像城市的去色彩化一样，
put a lot of focus on crumbling infrastructure, right? Suddenly, it kind of thrusts that into the spotlight. So what about all those concerns from business leaders about people not being able to wayfind or being too dark at night? I mean, not too surprisingly. A lot of those were a bit overblown. And it turns out that, yes, people can still find their way around cities without ads. And a lot of building owners ended up repainting their facades. So, a lot of structures ended up looking better and more distinctive anyway.
让很多目光聚焦到了摇摇欲坠的基础设施上，对吧？突然之间，它把这些问题推到了聚光灯下。那么商业领袖们担心的那些问题呢，比如人们无法辨别方向或者晚上太黑？我的意思是，毫不意外。其中很多担忧都被夸大了。事实证明，是的，人们在没有广告的情况下仍然可以在城市中找到方向。而且很多建筑业主最终重新粉刷了他们的外墙。因此，无论如何，许多建筑最终看起来更好、更有特色了。
So this all started like a decade ago. Is South Paulo still totally ad-free today? Well, some ads have actually been allowed back up, but it's all much more controlled than it used to be. There's this new awareness about how things look and how useful they are. So for example, there are these interactive search engine ads at bus shelters that let riders look up the weather where they're going. And part of the deal is
所以这一切大约始于十年前。今天圣保罗仍然完全没有广告吗？嗯，有些广告实际上已经被允许重新挂出来了，但比起过去，现在受到的控制要严得多。人们对事物的视觉外观和实用性有了这种新的认识。因此，举个例子，公交候车亭里有这些交互式搜索引擎广告，让乘客可以查询他们要去目的地的天气。其中的一部分交易是
that marketers have to actually take care of those bus shelters. So it's kind of like an adopt a highway program. You can put a little ad as long as you provide something good for the community. Yeah, yeah, it's like adopt a highway program with a, you know, a sort of technology twist. And I was actually just reading about something else that the current mayor proposed last year. His idea is to reintroduce exactly 32 billboards, each one for one of the 32 main bridges that run around the city. And the idea there is that marketers can advertise on these only if they agree to maintain that
营销人员实际上必须照顾好这些公交候车亭。所以这有点像“认养高速公路”项目。只要你为社区提供一些好的东西，你就可以放一个小广告。是的，是的，这就像“认养高速公路”项目，只不过加入了某种技术转折。我其实刚刚读到现任市长去年提出的另一项提议。他的想法是重新引入整整 32 个广告牌，每一个广告牌对应环绕城市的 32 座主要桥梁中的一座。其背后的想法是，只有当营销人员同意维护
bridge that, you know, each billboard is associated with. Like the bus shelters, they have to use some of the digital display space to actually show useful stuff, like traffic updates and the time and the weather. That's very cool. It's remarkable to see how a city goes about selectively reintroducing advertising once they start with a clean slate. Yeah, and it's something that, you know, most cities just aren't bold enough to do. Like, they just never, never get a chance to do that, right?
与每个广告牌相关的桥梁时，他们才被允许在这些广告牌上做广告。就像公交候车亭一样，他们必须使用部分数字显示空间来展示真正有用的东西，比如交通更新、时间和天气。这太酷了。令人惊叹的是，当一座城市从一张白纸开始时，它是如何有选择性地重新引入广告的。是的，这是大多数城市根本没有胆量去做的事情。就像，他们永远、永远没有机会做到这一点，对吧？
Yeah. And so when you do, you want to be deliberate. You want to make sure it's for the public good. Yeah, it's a really great experiment to sort of watch unfold. That's so cool. And we have some pictures of these on the website. Oh, yeah. The before and after shots are really quite stunning.
是的。所以当你有机会时，你就会想要深思熟虑。你要确保这是为了公众的利益。是的，看着这一切展开，真是一个非常棒的实验。太酷了。我们在网站上有一些这些照片。哦，是的。前后对比照真的相当震撼。
Cool. We'll check it out at 999PI.org. Thanks, Kurt. [♪ Music playing in background, playing inereef Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial." Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead, is the digital director. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. The rest of the team is Avery Choffman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars.
酷。我们去 999PI.org 查看。谢谢你，库尔特。[背景音乐播放中，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。]凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。我们的资深编辑是黛兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。团队的其他成员包括艾弗里·霍夫曼（Avery Choffman）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza），以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
Special thanks again to the Billboard Boys team who are just delightful to work with. Their movie is so fun to watch. Billboard Boys is available on Amazon and iTunes. Additional info is available at BillboardBoys.com. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
再次特别感谢Billboard Boys团队，与他们合作非常愉快。他们的电影非常好看。《Billboard Boys》可以在亚马逊和iTunes上观看。更多信息请访问BillboardBoys.com。我们是旧金山91.7K ALW的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row。《99% Invisible》是来自PRX的Radio Topia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请访问radiotopia.fm了解详情。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have pictures of AdFilled and AdFree, so I'll follow. At 99PI.org. Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars或@99PIOrc。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们在99PI.org上有包含广告和无广告版本的图片，所以我会关注的。来自PRX的Radio Topia。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。